let's explore a bit how the price of an
option can vary or how it can relate to
the actual expiration date so what i'm
going to do is compare two similar
options with the underlying stock being
general electric and they're going to be
saying the same in every way except one
is going to have a further out
expiration date so let's compare let's
compare this call option right here so
this is a call option on ge with a 17
strike price so it's the option to buy
ge stock at 17
and it has an april 2011 expiration so
it's going to expire or the last day of
trading that you could trade this option
will be the third friday in april let's
compare that with the the same the
an option that has the same strike price
but has a december
2011 expiration so we're going to look
for 17 dollar strike price right over
here and you can see right when you
compare the options that the one that
has a further out expiration costs more
this one costs three dollars and 25
cents while this one only costs two
dollars and 36 cents and the reason why
it costs more is because you have you
get to retain the option for longer so
you can imagine seventeen dollars let's
say that seventeen dollars is right over
here let me draw a hypothetical stock
chart so let's say that seventeen
dollars
is right over here and so you can
imagine let's say that you have both of
those options or or you have the option
to have either one of those options and
let's say that the stock does something
let's say that the stock does something
like that
well it's going to be in the money you
have the right if you own either one of
those options if you own either one of
those options you have the option to buy
the stock at seventeen dollars and then
sell it at whatever price this is maybe
this price over here is like twenty
something dollars so you would make
money but if you have the option with a
closer with a closer expiration with the
april 2011 expiration you have to
exercise the option right now you would
have to exercise it right now and close
out the option if you had the longer
dated option you could do it you could
do the exact same thing with the that
this owner of an april 2011 option has
or you can hold the option and maybe see
if the stock continues to go up or you
can imagine a downside scenario someone
who has maybe the stock does something
like this where it goes out of the money
someone who holds the closer dated
option the one that that expires first
they'll be completely out of the money
the option would be worthless on this
date but if you have the up if you have
the the longer expiration if your option
does not expire until december of 2011
then you can hold it and maybe maybe the
stock will do something nice there's
some probability that it will one day
become in the money and i want to make
it clear even if you have the situation
here and you hold the longer dated
option you have the option that's going
to expire
in december you still would not want to
exercise it because there is someone who
would still enjoy all of this
optionality of the future so what you're
better off doing instead of exercising
the option you're better off selling the
longer dated option right over there and
you should be able to capture at least
as much profit as you would from
exercising the option plus capturing
whatever value your the buyer sees in
the future optionality